[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
q and a cat infestation
we are going to attempt to address your
questions with answers that hopefully
you will find suitable if
they are not suitable i don't know what
we can do about it
but perhaps we'll set up a process it's
a process
yeah a process yeah all right
so we will start with a few questions
from episode 50
and uh then we're going to pull one uh
that was
sent in from the discord server and then
begin with questions
um at the highest monetary level from
last hour and then
finally uh answer questions from this
area that come in in
the order in which they come in although
we as always reserve the right to pick
and choose since we never get through
all of them
question from last time
is there hi friend uh is there an ess
that is an evolutionarily stable
strategy
likely to evolve over time as in decades
after sufficient number of oscillations
of power between right and left that
will eventually result in policies that
are not
polar uh yes
problem being there is nothing that
guarantees you don't go extinct before
you get there so the
tendency will be to go in that direction
the
danger is that we won't make it and
the solution of course involves
us consciously thinking about our
desire not to go extinct and
blueprinting
a prototype that might replace the
system so anyway i think there's a lot
to be said about
what we might do to stop that dangerous
oscillation
um the stinginess of the right the
utopianism of the left
and the hazard that they repeatedly
place us in so the way to fast forward
the process is to talk about the hazard
and what might get us out of it
yeah and i mean the ess itself is going
to be dynamic uh
just like um you know it will
itself include oscillations it has to
there's not going to be a set point
there's not it's it won't it can't be
static well
it can be a little bit like the
temperature of one's
body where it is maintained within
relatively tight tolerances in other
words i don't think it can be i think
it's
more like say a lot of volterra dynamics
between predator and
prey that's the problem is that dynamic
and the question is can you build
something that recognizes that that
dynamic in this case
places you in danger something that
serves the
function of
basically homeostasis and does the
the job that that oscillation does can
you make
the body politic act like an individual
organism
right and i i'm surprised to hear you
say that you think
one can i don't think we have a choice
uh i really but i mean
not having a choice and it being
possible are not
the not just because you don't think we
have a choice doesn't mean that it's
possible well
clearly you can at some scales and the
question is can we scale it up
so that the the job is done but clearly
the hazard of oscillating back and forth
is so great that the
long-term well-being of the body politic
depends on us taming that dynamic
so i do think there's a way there
maybe a domestication process rather
than imagining that
a group can act like an individual well
i think we are beginning to have the
conversation
that recognizes that the tension between
right and left
is a navigation mechanism
that i think we for the first time i
believe we know where
we want to go right and we humans
no uh we the west okay
um i believe we know what the end state
looks like and that it's already been
spelled out and what we differ over
is how close we are how quickly we could
go
further in that direction but you know
a society in which
the tools to compete
are available without bias
and in which uh one's
misfortune is hedged out by a protective
mechanism and therefore people are
liberated to try
to bring benefit to humanity
that is the liberal west right the fact
that the liberal west has never gotten
there that they've always been
populations that have been excluded from
access to the market and all means that
there's a lot of work to do but it
doesn't mean that there's anything we
need to learn
about where we're headed
so i would say it's a little bit like
the discovery
that a sphere minimizes surface to
volume ratio
right you could have a sphere and you
could say well what's better than a
sphere well nothing's better than a
sphere
and then we can look at all the things
that look spherical and we can say how
close really are they
um so in this case i think we know what
works
we are in danger of taking it apart and
having to rebuild it
because of some utopian nonsense about
some
equitable thing that would be better
than
than the thing that the west aspires to
but if we can
if we can survive the the allergic
reaction that people are having
to the goal of the liberal west and
figure out how to measure where we
actually are and how to keep going in
this direction which we've been
successfully doing for hundreds of years
um
it seems to me that we can do that and
the recognition
that a system in which the right thinks
we want to do x
and the left thinks we want to do y is
actually a hazard
um and that therefore the left and right
should be interested
in taming the dynamic so that they can
each play their roles but
with respect to getting to a common goal
is
clearly the right answer all right
44 states have science ed standards
based on the next gen sci standards
these standards require a shift in
instruction and learning that might
surprise you
would you be opposed to doing a special
series with separate episodes discussing
each high school science standard
so i had um this came in last time and i
looked at it i didn't i forgot to pull
it up again
for this hour um and it is it is a
little surprising what it is they're
proposing
i don't think i think it's unlikely that
um our time is going to end up being
spent
going through uh a new set of standards
um i in general i don't i don't want to
spend time on the particulars of the
moment
um for on
on any number of topics um
because looking for the patterns uh that
are that are larger
are just for a number of reasons just
what are more interesting to me but
um i did look at these i don't know if
you've heard of them
at all um and i was pleasantly surprised
to see that uh some of them
uh the the new science standards do seem
to be about inquiry
and actual science as opposed to
wokeness
and shutting down questioning we'll see
if they survive
yeah has donnie paved the way for a flat
earth president is it feasible to
flatten the earth to meet demands
um yeah i'm
i don't even know what to do with that
you know is it donny
is it the dynamic that left the door
open
to to trump i mean it i just don't
understand why we're having
this conversation as if he emerged out
of nowhere and forced his way into the
system
what conversation do you think we're
having that you don't understand
um a partisan one
the system uh has
cancer or rabies or something and i
think we're still having a
um you know an argument about
you know the left half of the raccoon is
less rabid
and therefore we have to support the
left half of the raccoon
rather than oh my god the raccoon has
rabies
we're going to have to get rid of it and
replace it with a raccoon that doesn't
okay not that we need raccoons but i
mean we do oh we'd need
we like raccoons yes all right i've
gotten that tangled no that was good
i think that helped you emerge from
whatever funk you were in there briefly
that's good just get you on the topic of
raccoons or perhaps hedgehogs
oh no not again no
enough too many hedgehogs for one week
oh mike too much
too much hedgehog for one lifetime wow
really
yeah no i would like to see hedgehogs
that's why this comes up
yes every time you speak with douglas
for instance yes
yes for example are biological parents
replaceable with surrogate or foster
parents
if so what do adopted children lose that
only a biological lineage can provide
go um lots to say here
um
a family that has entirely adopted
children
uh is uh
un it is is likely to uh
have very few problems
uh that a family with entirely genetic
children
uh might have that the um that the
genetic lineage part of the relationship
between parent and offspring
is is not largely something that looms
looms large in daily life i think um
it is difficult uh and i speak from
experience in my own natal family and
from hearing many other stories like it
when there are both genetic and adopted
children in the home
that that that you know even when
everyone is trying their absolute best
on that there is conflict that that
erupts
uh almost always so
i don't know what more you want to say
about that
well i would just say there is no bar
to an adoptive parent being an excellent
parent there are things that make it
less likely
mixed brood being one of them we know
that from
lots of research that says such
households are much more prone to all
the things that go wrong
but the
i mean the problem is we are seeing the
collapse of parenting
all over the place because in large
measure our circumstances are too novel
and uh parents have antagonists
that are trying to persuade kids of
things that aren't true for their own
economic reasons and so anyway there's a
you know there are so many things going
wrong
that um focusing on
a what might be a small difference
in the likeliness of an adoptive parent
being an excellent parent uh
i think is just wrong-headed we're
seeing a failure of parenting all over
the place and
really the point is what what goes into
excellent parenting and how can we
bootstrap a return to a culture in which
parenting is
basically functional and that will
bring adoptive parents along just as
much as anyone else
all right final question from episode 50
would you fly seven hours to see elderly
relatives for holidays
then stay with family in a hotel for two
days is this unsafe given the pandemic
note that the destination state requires
a test or 14 day quarantine
so i included this not because i think
we can answer
it because i think you just you need to
know more about everyone's
risk tolerance and the particularities
of how careful people are being and
and and all of this but um
i i wanted to just say this out loud
because i suspect that this is something
that a lot of people
are wrestling with uh right now as as
the holidays approach
um you know how is it that
after gosh two-thirds of a year
of almost yeah almost
of of some combination of lockdowns and
just
you know complete disorder at almost
every level of
of life uh how
valuable are the
the shared memories that you would
create around holidays together which is
so
often a time that families see each
other who don't otherwise have time to
see each other
you know what what is a break you know
for people who have an annual tradition
for whom that that part of the annual
tradition has actually not yet been
disrupted
what might disrupting regular traditions
that occur
at that level of cyclicity due to
further
cause disorder and i i don't know but i
think it's potentially big
i think that there's been so much
disruption this year but there's like
tether
on the holiday season that can mean a
lot of different things for a lot of
different people for some people it's
thanksgiving for some people it's
christmas uh for some it's you know
hanukkah isn't a real holiday but um but
you know it's
it's a minor holiday i not real but
um you know for for most
people there is some holiday at the end
of the year that feels like
the thing that uh that they experience
that they
that they return home for the solstice
um and giving up on all of that
may create even greater
mental health disruption than we've than
we've yet seen that said
people often complain about the family
time around holidays
um and you know missing it might
actually reveal
that it wasn't as bad as you thought so
you know there's a lot going on here and
i don't know the answer
yeah i think a it could be very
hazardous
in the sense of the annual check-in
that people typically experience may
have a calibration
function that we don't missing it could
be hazardous is what you mean absolutely
um obviously there's a huge danger of
uh you know a
not a super spreader event but a super
spreader moment where people
are gathering and suddenly
versions of the virus are spreading
around which could be
hazardous in its own right one thing i
would say that i think
we have been discovering of late is
this is actually a perfect model for
what we were talking about before
about the oscillation between left and
right at the moment we have two
narratives about virus and
carefulness surrounding it both of which
are wrong
and the
the little bit of travel that we have
just done
and the gathering with people where we
have
seen very few outside of our immediate
circle
for you know two-thirds of a year
has revealed that there's a problem
also the change in season all of these
things have revealed that there is a
problem with the fact that we have not
reached agreement on what we are trying
to accomplish
and therefore how to collectively make
good decisions in other words
there should be some discussion before
you gather with people
about how you're going to minimize the
chances that if one of the people
at the gathering has coveted that it
will not spread to others in other words
is there an opportunity
to meet outside what is the
code of conduct with respect to masks
does the fact that i'm not wearing a
mask while we are meeting outside
mean that i am against masks no so
you know basically it would be great if
a socially distant group
outside didn't wear masks because
they're unnecessary
put them on without anybody having to
remind anybody as you go indoors
that you spend as little time as
possible
in very enclosed spaces you prefer rooms
that are
larger you prefer windows that are open
you prefer fans that are on
yeah it's really tough to do for most of
the country though in november and
december
right so what that means is that all of
these things have changed and so what
we've discovered is that we had a really
good
pattern that we were all in on
and it just became we the four of us and
our family here our immediate family
had a pattern where you know we had we
were making use of
restaurants always outdoors
right and we you know we were very
careful about
windows and things when somebody came
into the house
and the problem is the weather is now
taking the behaviors that were working
and upending them and so what that's
resulting in
is a kind of since we're not in the
frame of mind of thinking about
covet every minute of the day anymore
because we've just gotten used to it
we're now you know thinking well
we're not even thinking so it's the idea
is that restaurants
were possible because outdoors was safe
and it isn't
highly transmissible in food so
um the temptation is you know we're back
in restaurant mode where that
restaurants are a possibility but
they may again not be a possibility
based on the fact the weather means that
outdoor dining isn't happening anymore
so all of these things require
sort of a
rebooting of the conscious discussion of
how can we prevent
each other from getting coveted if
somebody brings it to a gathering
and this is much more important than
some fraction of the population seems to
believe at the moment based on
the dire consequences for some people
who get this thing
these months and months and months of
you know myriad different symptoms
yep i will say that on our recent
just four day trip uh to uh
a place even farther north than we are
now uh we
went to eat outside in a mexican
restaurant and it turns out that despite
what their website said
they were only open for takeout but they
were selling margaritas to
drink while you waited for your takeout
so we sat outside
and drank extraordinarily cold
margaritas under a very cold sky and
darkening sky
and i thought this is not the conditions
under which margaritas were invented
this is not this is
not the right circumstance to be
drinking margaritas at all yeah but the
food was
freezing your ass off in margaritaville
exactly
exactly all right um question from the
discord this week
humans are running on ten
thousand-year-old hardware
what's the evolutionary explanation for
groups tearing themselves apart in moral
panics like the kathar heresy
salem witch trials the red scare and
cancel culture
so i'll let you take this um i will say
that some of what
well two things first before you take it
is that some of what we talked about
with regard to eric hoffer
uh was uh addressed some of this a bit
and then i'm not sure where the number
ten thousand year old hardware comes
from
i think we've got twenty uh rather two
hundred thousand year old hardware
the ten thousand number the number that
that reminds me of is
uh ten to twelve thousand years or so is
about when agriculture was popping up in
multiple places around the world
independently evolved
uh in three four five places depending
um so our hardware is a lot older uh
than 10 000 years
but other than that well you know what
we say
in our book is that the hardware varies
a lot so we've got
you know the basic platform was fully in
place a couple hundred thousand years
ago
there's obviously some hardware level
stuff that's altered
in the post farming era for humanity
um you know most of the hardware almost
all of the hardware will be
quite a bit more ancient than 10 000
years but it doesn't really matter for
this question because the basic answer
is
you're dealing with um evolved software
and i don't think the moral panics
of this kind would have been very common
uh
pre-agriculture because the
uh the shared fate aspect
of very small groups of people living
together wouldn't have
tolerated it and so you know you're
dealing with
the 10.0 or 12.0 version of the culture
and that's where these things happen and
i do think it has a lot to do with what
we discussed in the first hour
where you have competitive dynamics that
cause
a group that is in a position to do it
to freeze out another group that isn't
in a position to
defend itself those who are frozen out
rebel against the
meritocratic system because they're not
well armed for it and therefore would be
its losers
and they uh topple it which causes a
catastrophe and you know
rents repeat um
awesome i knew i could bring shampoo
into it
um so yeah so anyway that's that's what
it is you're dealing with a
culturally evolved phenomenon not a
genetically evolved one yeah this does
remind me of the
to me somewhat inexplicable final
paragraph of this book which
i didn't share i haven't shared i didn't
share any of what i was going to talk
with you about before we went on
yeah we'll see if i can explicit once
you've uh yeah explicit
okay fair enough remember written in
1951
jbs haldane counts fanaticism among the
only four really important inventions
made between 3000 bc and 1400 a.d
it was a judaic christian invention and
it is strange to think that in receiving
this malady of the soul the world
also received a miraculous instrument
for raising societies and nations from
the dead
an instrument of resurrection
like where does that paragraph even come
from
he's finishing with the holidays one of
the important i like the the idea that
fanaticism
has an origin you know the
judeo-christian
tradition although like on what basis so
haldane is one of the framers of the
modern synthesis
yeah right yeah yeah so he was a very
important early mid
uh 20th century evolutionary biologist
if you can hear that that is zach the
producer
trying to deal with the two kittens and
their penchant for i don't know what
they're doing eating pens
something destroying curtains something
bad yeah um
so you know his halt apparently haldane
which i really didn't expect to see
holding quoted in this book
and it wasn't he wasn't until the very
last paragraph like i said
um counts fanaticism among the only four
really important inventions made between
3000 bc and 1480. how would he even like
where did he just pull those numbers out
of his ass i think
i don't know he's a pretty careful
thinker um it sort of needs more than
the paragraph to know what he was
what he was getting at yeah all right
okay first question from last hour
episode 51
twin studies etc show that shared family
environment only accounts for a small
percentage and variance of intelligence
in adulthood
can an individual parent still have a
large influence by using an unorthodox
parenting style
and becoming a statistical outlier on
purpose
yes i would caution people i don't think
we know nearly as much about
how these things are inherited and there
are
many very subtle mechanisms by which
things can appear to be genetically
encoded and therefore
parents have very little influence yadda
yadda this can't
possibly be right it cannot logically
be correct right so the question is how
is it incorrect
and once you're at the how is it
incorrect then the landscape is pretty
open
from the point of view of
mechanisms to influence so
do not take this stuff as gospel that
says there's very little that can be
done the very fact of parenting being
the highly intensive long-standing
activity that it is
and childhood being so darn long tells
you that this is a very important
set of interactions exactly we have we
have the longest childhoods
per life span of anyone on the planet
and
every organism with a long childhood uh
has a long childhood because they are
being parented
and they are learning how to be the
adults they will become this is what
childhood
is that's not childhood that's stasis
so also rotifers i suspect like
being able to just cheating that was
cheating no
well they do have a variable also not
all hashtags right not all cicadas
cicadas only periodicals oh this is
getting
this is getting ugly yep um no but they
do have this
very long larval stage attached to the
roots of
trees yes um 13 or 17 years
yes everything else that has a long
childhood has a long childhood i mean
there's probably other exceptions i just
don't think that counts as childhood
for one thing well it's a dreary
childhood i will grant you that
and it's totally isolated i don't think
that we need actually to
um accessorize the term childhood by
specifying that it's
it's with others of your species but um
that's
that's the primary reason that i am
declaring that the
childhood of periodical cicadas for 13
or 17 years is not in fact a
childhood all right
okay both men and women parentheses
mammals
are physiologically sexually activated
with erection or clitoral encouragement
during rem sleep from a very young age
onward even though the content of our
dreams is often not of romantic nature
do you have a hypothesis why
um i don't think we have the ability
to know what such states are correlated
with
cognitively i mean how would we even
um so right what i would say
is you've you've got a system
in which the purpose of the system is
the propagation of certain genetic
spellings
and i mean this is the reason human
beings are fascinated by sex is that it
it matters evolutionarily and so at some
level
dreams are an adaptive phenomenon this
is clear
by virtue of the fact that they're
expensive and persistent
it is not surprising that there is
sexually relevant content
throughout them and that
it has some sort of
relationship to physiological states i
mean i mean we could we could
uh we could pursue this in all kinds of
directions but i would just say you've
got a state dependence issue
where arousal
accompanies sexual success
in waking life and therefore the
scenario building surrounding attaining
that success in sleeping life
should be accompanied with physiological
states that are
um consistent with it
so something in that neighborhood but i
guess what i would say is i think i
think i hear in your question
the suggestion that those physiological
states during rem sleep
are uh uncorrelated
with dreams that would make sense of
them and i just don't know how we would
know that if there's a way to know that
i'd be very
curious and your suspicion is that
um there is sexual romantic content in
related to i think physiological social
activity
i would put it in a different way which
is sure to be misunderstood
but basically if all human activity
is a means to an end that goes through
sexual interaction then what exactly
is you know what is
non-sexual thought the point is it all
heads that direction though very
indirectly
right so um anyway it's a high bar but
yep would a biden win
effectively reward and reinforce
pre-election political violence
i am a lifelong democrat no fun of trump
no fan of trump
but to me a dem win would mean the
normalization of political violence and
all election years henceforth would be
like 2020.
um yeah they're throwing a tantrum
and uh they are
yeah i i think yes and yet i've heard
exactly the opposite argument as well
that a trump win will uh
mean that the pre-election political
violence gets worse
uh and therefore that's why you need to
vote for
for biden i mean maybe that's maybe
that's the same argument i kind of
i feel like i've heard all versions of
this and i don't think i just quite
said exactly the opposite version that i
was trying to but i think people are
talking themselves into well
there's a simple answer and it involves
doing x or not doing x
yeah but i don't think this question is
a simple
this strikes me as true oh i think it's
absolutely true
um but what i would say is violence is a
means to an end
the end has to do with power and
resources
so what i would say is i would expect
a trump win to produce one reaction
which might
well be a continuation
of violence and i would expect
a biden win to change
the nature at which power is being
wielded
what i do not expect which i have heard
people argue
for is the idea that if biden wins
this madness the woke madness will stop
right i think this is utter nonsense it
is completely illogical
this woke madness is about power
it has discovered how much power it has
and it has
every reason to continue that
irrespective of who wins
and so i would expect it to function
through the biden administration yes
even if it doesn't remain in the streets
yeah
it'll look different but this just this
continues the lie and some people
i think are generally confused but some
people are just lying
when they say that the craziness that we
saw
in fact after the 2016 election was a
result of the 2016 election
no and you know we we saw a particular
version of it of course
being still at evergreen at that time
but
all of the you know chaos and
you know even violence that happened on
the campus of evergreen
that year after november whatever it was
2016 when trump was elected through
you know through may 23rd 2017 and
beyond when the protests and the riots
first
erupted um in force at evergreen
were not the beginning they were not the
beginning campus was
already going crazy for years before
then and
um it was facilitated by leadership that
tolerated it
and so you know look look to the
leadership who's tolerating this
and don't imagine that this is somehow
trump's fault this is that i mean that
is that is a
ridiculously juvenile argument yeah just
it doesn't
fit with how this unfolded no it doesn't
it trump changed it
for sure and and he played it and he and
he profited from it
but um he did not create it yep he did
not create it
oh where am i here we go hey brett
hey brett france gets 75 of their
electricity from nuclear power
some five-eyed children just saw a
mushroom cloud rise over the minarets of
paris
three out of two people have cancer
naturally i stand with you on your
villainization of nuclear power
thank goodness your math needs work
um come on let's not play games like
this um
the fact is nuclear power
is a gamble when nuclear when fission
power was first deployed
for electrical power generation the idea
was that we would figure out what to do
with the waste and we never have and
what's more we've proven
that the mechanisms that we thought
might work don't so
i'm not demonizing nuclear power for one
thing as i keep saying
nuclear power isn't one thing it's two
opposite things
and i am very much a proponent of the
second thing that is to say fusion power
with respect to fission power is there a
way it could be done safely i remain to
be
convinced but it certainly can't be done
safely with the modern
or the most recent generation of
reactors
you would need different reactors you
might need a different fuel source
um but because of the potential for
positive feedback and runaway meltdowns
yeah yeah the meltdown potential and
even even when it doesn't melt down the
generation of large amounts of waste
that
is uh highly radioactive for thousands
of years
is um you know it's just going to
continue to build up
it's eventually going to find its way
into the environment
so you know let's not pretend this is a
simpler problem than it is
it seems like moral systems need a place
to experiment and to evolve
they have such long-term consequences
that we can't design them
would you agree how would we create
these spaces
it seems like moral systems need a place
to experiment well
a we have this
um what we don't have is a proper
boundary in other words we have
tremendous freedom
to choose our level of adherence inside
of a moral system and this is a feature
of almost all maybe all religious
structures for example there are people
who are orthodox there are people who
are more liberal in their
view and in some sense these things are
in competition with
each other and so that experimentation
occurs the hazard becomes in secular
society
or pluralistic society you have the
danger of
profiting from opting out of moral
restrictions that
bind everyone else and so
a temporary advantage to
atheists or those who behave like them
can destabilize an entire system
because not everybody is equally bound
so that i think is the hazard within any
of these
groups a sectarian
or other difference in levels of
adherence
naturally runs the experiment in
question
yeah that's true and i guess i would add
to that just i i would have i would have
framed this slightly differently and
said
um this reminds me of adaptive
landscapes right that you are
if if you are looking for a moral system
that is better than the one that you
or the populace are in you cannot
blueprint it and say go there you can
get off the peak you're on and get onto
another slope and and see what happens
and that's you know what what does that
get on a different slope and see what
happens look like like how do you create
that space
i don't have a decent answer and i think
that's part of what you were trying to
answer there but
i totally agree uh that designing the
endpoint
is not going to be the savvy way to do
it savvy
approach because it's just not going to
be possible
the left seems highly capable of
unearthing
parentheses generating problems however
it does not seem capable at all of
solving them
does it lack any sort of implementation
arm does it gate keep people
that would be in said arm based on
aesthetics
um i'm not sure what that last part
means i'm not
the left i mean if you mean the
american blue team that's one thing
um but the left itself i mean
progressives have engaged in a
tremendous amount of highly effective
solution
making and are not getting credit
because
that which passes for progressive these
days is so crazy that it makes it look
like it's an insane way to think right
right now
not so much but from the i don't know
60s 70s uh and before
absolutely yeah well i would also say
you know in light of
the um consideration of of hoffer's book
that you engaged in in the first hour
there is there's a dynamic
that has to be on unpacked to the extent
that what is
passing is left now are basically
authoritarians
rejecting a system that's not the same
thing as actual progressives proposing
how society might be altered bettered
fixed yes yes good
you spoke of jordan peterson's book maps
of meaning and its cover art
it is a sculpture he made in 1985 as a
graduate student
called the meaning of music to be an
object that changes as you look at it
like a necker cube
what did it remind brett of
[Music]
um we don't have it else i'd show it
here
yeah the what it reminded me of
is what i called
pie chart language so
there is a missing
um a missing
bridge between psychological thinking
and evolutionary thinking it's not that
it is not
obvious to many people that such a
bridge is necessary but the first forays
into
making that bridge um basically
evolutionary ecology
kind of died on the vine and it did not
take over and fuse the two disciplines
the way it should have
so as i was trying to build
the proper tools for thinking about
evolution and ecology
it became clear that one needed to use
pie charts in order to understand
populations growth frontiers
etc and that what happened is that
slices of pie grew
so they didn't fit the original confines
of the pie
and anyway i built a little proto
language that allowed
the description of an event in terms of
how it affected the fortunes of multiple
populations simultaneously dividing up a
world of resources in which the world of
resources
changed its volume based on what was
discovered
so basically once you move from zero in
from zero sum into non-zero sum dynamics
you can still use this
new form of pie chart pie charts haven't
been much reviled
in in scientific literature but you were
using this new form of pie charts
to describe not just relative growth
within a population but the growth
of the opportunity uh under non-zero
sum dynamics uh positive sum negative
sum
and zero sum dynamics inhabiting the
same pie chart
um was what was necessary in order to
talk about
competition between populations for
example um anyway so it looked to me a
lot like
that diagram that's good i didn't know
that actually i
at some point i want to sit down with
jordan and talk to him about what he was
getting out there and see
if there's any analogy between them yeah
i am a mental health nurse now required
to attend healing racial trauma training
oh presenters website full of crt lingo
critical race theory lingo sent letter
to my human resources person with help
from james lindsay website
new discourses i'm now nervous in ann
arbor
thoughts love you too
um i'll bet ann arbor's gone a bit woke
that's where we did our graduate work
and it was a lovely lovely town but cold
at some times of the year but
hot at other times of the year yeah i
could deal with the hot more easily um
but yeah i'll bet that r1 university
in a relatively small town with a lot of
culture and a fair bit of uh federal
money coming in from grants
has made it pretty woke and i
feel your pain um you don't say what has
happened
you know maybe you've just sent the
letter to the to hr uh and you don't you
don't have a response yet
i don't know i don't know what to say
more than that i mean unfortunately i
think there is nothing to say it's
dangerous
i hope it goes well i do think we need
to develop
a modality as we started to on our last
podcast getting people to write down
their faulty claims so that they are
checkable in the future and that they
cannot escape them
is one feature of that landscape in this
case
if it's a training you can't you can't
ask the person doing the training
that one's applicable here but yeah what
would i do
here i think i would be trying to
introduce the idea
that that solution you are proposing is
a threat
to something that is serving everyone in
other words
there's a problem to be solved the
solution you are proposing to it
threatens to destroy much more than you
realize is in its scope
and i don't know frankly i don't think
an individual is going to be
in general in any position at all to do
that in a context like the one
you described but somehow to the extent
that we
as a larger group of people talking
about this can
lodge in the discussion um
and well in fact i was talking to
douglas murray
in my podcast with him several days ago
and he pointed out so my claim to him
was that the woke revolution
is actually going to destroy we've got a
system that fails to meet
its objective there's a gap between what
it does and what it aspires to do
but that the challenge to the
system as a whole is going to evaporate
the well-being that the system
is delivering and distributing yes
unfairly but distributing to everybody
and what douglas said that i was unaware
of he said
this is reminiscent of kant's point
about the bird that thinks
that um the air which is causing
uh um drag drag
yes uh is the obstacle to it flying
really fast and if only the air
could be done away with it would be that
much speedier when in fact wouldn't that
be the life
yeah it can't fly at all without the air
so
to the extent that we can start making
this point to people look you have no
idea what you are threatening
yes there are real problems with how
well-being
and opportunity are distributed there
just are um
but you're gonna kill the thing that
makes well-being exist at all
and it's not going to be good for
anybody including the people that you
think you're helping
um so i don't know that we can make that
resonate but it's the kind of thing
one person's saying it isn't going to be
enough saying it multiple times isn't
going to be enough
but to the extent that message begins to
come from different places
and it causes some who are on this
bandwagon to think oh
wait a second i could i could evaporate
the very thing that i'm trying to see
distributed
more fairly um yeah i'm trying to
enhance mental health for instance
um across people and
attending a healing racial trauma
training having having to
incorporate such thinking into the rest
of what i do
may actually cause everything to decline
in quality
yes i feel certain it absolutely will
but you obviously have to couch things
more gently for an audience that
can't hear it yeah and i would also just
add this whole idea of
healing racial trauma it sounds
so right and it is so backwards because
the fact is what you
actually need is opportunity if you've
been frozen out of opportunity what you
need
is opportunity and the tools to make use
of it and
my experience dealing with people all
over the world
is as soon as you have that
opportunity and the tools to utilize it
the trauma scars over
right it's not like it's gone it's not
like the history evaporates but the
point is it is not an obstacle to
day-to-day
well-being functioning happiness any of
those things as soon as the problem
is addressed well i mean this is an
analogy that you've used under
a lot of um in a lot of circumstances
here but it really
is so apt is that um
you don't we will all experience injury
in life some of it literal some of it
metaphorical and at first it creates
wounds
and long term short as short term as
possible
we hope that it scars over such that the
wounds are a thing of the past without
ever pretending that the injury did not
happen
you retain the scar you don't retain the
wound and that so much
of the modern ideology is about picking
and picking and picking and picking and
making sure that you never scar over so
there was always exposed wound to
display to people
and to announce about how how awful you
have it and
how it can never be made right and that
is in part
a result of the constant picking at it
yes
keeping the wound open because the wound
is your entitlement
to you know to be given something yeah
and like you know what the injury
happened what you know whatever in some
cases people are just making [ __ ] up
right but presume that there's something
real here the injury happened
the scar can still be your indicator of
injury but also allow you to move
forward
and a wound specifically keeps you mired
in the past and keeps you from
from becoming anything better and you
know part of part of it is exactly what
we're talking about in the first hour
you know you're your your pessimism
about about you know being able to fix
whole swathes of the population
is i i think in part based on um
you you seeing that so many people are
busy picking at their wounds
and uh and sure 100
i know it's not entirely i know there's
another big part of it which is that
they you know they
they arrive you are arguing
uh without uh an ability to
full without an ability to win in a
meritocracy yeah without tools
um but certainly it only makes it worse
if you if what is being told
to them and this is being this is
happening in the k-12 schools and higher
ed so this is happening for people
across
all levels where they still could
generate a toolkit with which to
actually move forward with
um creativity and analysis and
productivity
and if what they're being told instead
is
keep focusing on your wounds and the
wounds of others and how wounded they
are compared to you
uh well no one's going to win ultimately
except the very few people who are in
charge of
i don't know wound defining yeah i would
say that in
you know if we go back to the question
of
can we agree on a collective objective
that's
that uh replaces the you know the left
right
oscillation as a control mechanism the
point is look
you have an obligation to make yourself
as capable as possible
right to deal to scar over rather than
keep your wounds open
having done that we have an obligation
to make the system
fair right to the extent of the system
isn't fair
we have work to do but you also have
work to do and it is the partnership
between those things you make yourself
as capable as possible
yep we'll make the system fair you know
as quickly as possible
that's the shared objective and it
doesn't involve
i'm not going to make myself capable at
all because the reason i'm not capable
is
unfairness and you know take care of me
like that's just not
a stable long-term pattern
right are you kidding
okay uh we gotta get through three more
here and then we'll move into the next
uh
next hour's questions brett based on
your twitter banner you seem to like
pygmy owls
with how bad twitter and facebook are
why not come to discord instead
the darkhorse server even has a pick
meow keeping conversations civil and on
topic
hoot hoot so that pygmy owl picture
i am a uh
budding long-time nature photographer
and that pygmy owl
was a very lucky
get on my part i actually screwed it up
the first time i thought
it was a little piece of leaf matter
caught in a
tree and i walked up on it too quickly
and spooked it was this um
at camp westwood yeah uh on the oregon
coast yeah
with our class i was kicking myself this
beautiful animal had been
in a place where i could have taken a
great photo of it and it had flown off
because i
didn't interpret it correctly and i
thought you know
it looked awfully happy in that spot
i wonder if that's a hunting perch and
it sits there
often and so i on the
walk back i set the camera very
carefully for what i thought it was
gonna need
and i walked around the corner very
slowly so i didn't spook the animal and
sure enough he was sitting right there
and i shot a bunch of pictures and got a
good one
um nice so anyway i do like pygmy owls
diurnal owl by the way um
and uh that does not address your point
at all
twitter is a hazardous place it doesn't
deserve my owl picture and i should
take it somewhere else but anyway i'll
take it under advisement
from hi yes what's going on man um
from an evolutionary standpoint why is
violence reduced over the ages
has uh just the propensity for physical
violence reduced or has the concept of
violence just morphed into something
else
causing us to have a false sense of
security
um i would say that this is actually the
same thing that we've been kind of
addressing over several different
questions here which is
violence is not a good way of fixing
things it's a very
wasteful mechanism right does it work
does it keep people in line does the
threat of violence get them to
um do things that they should probably
but
the point is if you can get the same
system to reduce the violence necessary
in order to get people to behave in
other words if you can ritualize the
violence
or if you can encode it in something
else so it doesn't actually require
people to
[Music]
to engage in it that's better and so in
effect
we have all agreed to be less violent
in order to accomplish those things that
we agree are good when we accomplish
them
and i would expect that pattern to grow
greater and greater over time because
violence is
hazardous and uh and expensive that's
right
and i guess zack if you would just show
this screen for the moment
uh here's a robert sapolsky uh the great
robert sapolsky
uh writing in 2006 for foreign affairs
uh a piece that he called a natural
history of peace
something that i used to assign to my
animal behavior students which
i recommend this should be findable if
you search on a natural history of peace
sapolsky the magazine foreign affairs
and he walks through some of
what it is that we look like as humans
compared to some of the other primates
all right
final question here before we move over
to this hour's question so this is
actually someone
has written in several times
with a link here's a totally new
cyclical evolutionary hypothesis
the hypothesis explains political
polarizations through biology through
cyclical hormone levels in history
explains how hormone levels of oxytocin
and vasopressin create the left versus
right ideologies
and explains how populist nationalism is
created by hormones
so that link is
here zach you can show this again um i
believe the person writing in the
question is
is the author here it's a work in
progress it is
uh the title is cyclical evolution
hypothesis generationally oscillating
birth cohort specific hypothalamic
hormone levels
create physiological cognitive and
behavioral differences in cyclical
animal populations including human
populations
so obviously these just came in neither
of us had a chance to do anything but
read
the the title but my first reaction is
that this is putting the approximate
before the ultimate this is effectively
putting the cart before the horse
so it may well be true that you're onto
something interesting here
but citing hormone levels even you know
cyclically fluctuating hormone levels
that are reliable across
across individuals is primarily
approximate level analysis of what is
going on rather than an evolutionary
level analysis because the hormones will
follow
uh what is selected for um with
relatively rare uh um
events where you're just limited you
have you know phylogenetic constraints
so
you know for instance you know we can't
get to a better eye in vertebrates
because
um it would take require going through
blindness to get to
say a cephalopod eye um this will not be
clear to anyone who hasn't ever thought
about cephalopod eyes but um basically
like an
octopus eye is built better and we'd be
able to see better for more cheaply if
we had one of their eyes but in order to
make it we'd have to go back through not
having eyes at all and so
basically evolution can't get there
selection won't take us there
whereas cyclical hormone levels could be
could
could be modified and we know that they
do get modified pretty regularly so
i would say that the question is likely
to need to be
how do cyclical hormone levels serve
what is being selected for
as opposed to using the cyclical
hormone levels as an answer they are
in fact um an observation that warrants
a question
rather than an answer yeah i think it's
a little bit like
saying you know
20th century nation scale
violence is the result of
low voltage fluctuations
right because you don't go to war in the
20th century without making some phone
calls
and so if you were to track you know low
voltage oscillations on
phone wires you had no idea where you
were going wow
um if you were to track you know uh you
know phone calls out of the pentagon or
whatever
you might register there was a whole
bunch of uh
you know phone traffic and if you
mistook the phone traffic is causing the
wars you'd think
well this is important because it
happens it's every single war you get
you know
phone calls um okay so i
that's good i like that but it's not
quite sufficient i don't think because
that's a more standard like correlation
causation
conflation no no this is this is the
same thing
okay i'm saying exactly what you're
saying which is that the
um phone calls are involved in how wars
happen
and if you therefore track them you will
detect something but your point is
the evolutionary dynamics are going to
control why the hormones are fluctuating
rather than the hormones fluctuating
causing the dynamics so maybe it really
just
is maybe maybe the proximate ultimate
the the confusion that many many
many people have in science and biology
and evolutionary biology even although
more rarely have
between the proximate level the sort of
mechanism level of what's happening and
how it's happening versus the ultimate
level of why it's happening at the
evolutionary level
is in fact just a fancy deep history
conflation of correlation and causation
which i'd never actually thought to put
in those terms before but i think i
think that's right i think that is right
yeah so anyway i'd be interested in
looking more deeply into what you've
written and it's possible that
um it's just that the title is leading
us to imagine that this is
uh a conflation that's here but i would
guess if you're if you're thinking this
is downstream of the hormones
then the hormones are downstream of
something else and it would be well
worth understanding
what it was that caused the hormone
fluctuations yeah and you know not
not to say that um hormone levels aren't
you know aren't very interesting in fact
my
my um some of my prelim work
in grad school was looking at the ways
that androgens the so-called you know
male specific
hormones like testosterone and
androstenedione
actually affect um female behavior in um
in primates and actually drive things
like friendship between females
um so that is not the evolutionary you
know the
the bigger level evolutionary question
of like why you know why is there
sociality why do females have friends at
all what you know what drives those
friendships
um but looking at the hormonal
indicators of those friendships
is you know is another piece of the
puzzle that can be interesting so we're
not
um dismissing this uh just saying that
it's not likely to be the
top-level driver yeah it also raises the
question of whether or not you could
have
toxic masculinity in women absolutely oh
my god that's a frightening thought
i'm not really okay
questions from this hour bret
if the opportunity to fix my toolkit has
been largely lost
he's quoting i thank you from last hour
why am i listening to you
are you saying i should just die maybe
rethink that
so obviously slightly snarky here but i
mean this i
i feel him like this is what i felt
pushing back against you at the end of
last hour like what
like really yeah but okay here's the
thing a human being is a fantastically
capable creature and we are all being
hobbled by this very
stupid civilization that takes what
could be marvelous tools
and dulls them for decade upon decade
before
setting you loose to do someone else's
bidding in the marketplace
so are you damaged no
doubt my friend you're damaged are you
in a position to better yourself of
course you are and you should
right whatever damage we have all
sustained and however much we may have
lost out on opportunities that we might
have availed ourselves of
the difference between throwing in the
towel
and attempting to make the tools as
sharp as possible and wield them as well
as possible it's a gigantic difference
so of course you should upgrade them but
i don't want to pretend like we're in a
position
to uh to make you a you know a
journeyman whatever
if the opportunity has been lost right
so
you know and please don't take this the
wrong way
at some level it isn't about you
it's about the fact that we are going to
continue to do this for generation
after generation of human beings that
are not yet damaged
right we do not have to damage them in
the same way
even if we are not fully rescueable so
let's get over the idea that we need to
be fully rescueable
for rescue to be a worthwhile topic and
let's just please
not do it to any more kids yeah
amen you hate the dnc
yeah you know me you hate the rnc yeah
you know me
you hate fb policy yep you know me
who's down with unity this whole podcast
live stream
that wasn't a question no that was some
kind of poetry yeah yeah
um from someone else who sometimes gives
us poetry oh wait a second no
that's a permutation
of a song lyric which i can't quite
resurrect
so you would be far more likely than me
um
yeah i'd look it up if you would zack
okay i'm going to move on tell us when
you got it
after 2016 i asked myself what the left
could have done to lose to this guy and
i came upon identity politics and
abandoning the working class
if trump wins again how can we best ask
this if lefties after this election
oh my god the left really seems
determined um
really seems determined to uh not learn
the lessons
it does and so determined the idea i
mean really at some level
one wants to say
you did this and if you don't understand
how that happened you're gonna keep
doing it
and it won't last you have to stop and
this is
this is in fact exactly why i'm
completely unpersuaded by any of these
arguments about
you must vote for more or whatever it is
that people are telling you you must
vote for in this context
the answer is unless you are thinking
about the fact that this dynamic is
making things worse and worse over time
and that we have to escape
it then you're not in a position to say
who you must vote for because
as bad as trump is he could be far worse
and
it is not at all clear that biden
coming into power isn't going to make
things worse by
um cynically playing along with this
woke ideology so
we haven't been given a good option
you're going to therefore avail yourself
of a
not so good option whatever it may be
this is exactly the topic
i wrote about in my essay right before
the conclusion of the 2016 election
there is not a single choice you could
make in that election
that rendered you harmless um we are
once again there
um
i'm not going to look it up and try i've
never heard it so i
i can't possibly do justice to it yep um
or i don't know that i've heard it i
don't at least recognize it from
those modified lyrics okay
following your episode on evolutionary
dentistry can you discuss evolutionary
ophthalmology
should kids wear glasses what's your
take on refractive surgery oh
man echo such good questions always from
you
um yeah we should we should
we should spend some time another time
talking about this in some more depth
um if
let me take the slightly easier part
first if you're if your question about
refractive surgery is like lasik
which i think it's going to be so like
um
basically cutting um cutting slits
in the cornea to change the curvature of
the lens
um if we had the precision to actually
do that and and
we expected that the eye wasn't changing
shape over time which it is
um then it might be it it might be a
reasonable surgery i was actually
days away from having that surgery
myself um i have i've
had myopia since i was pretty bad in my
opiates since i was 13.
and um i was lucky
enough to have ended up with a crazy eye
fungus from madagascar which
put had me forced to put the surgery off
which i'd scheduled for after i came
back from this
five-month field trip field season in
madagascar
during which time i spent some more time
looking into what
success and lasik actually means and
it turns out that anything at 2200 or
better
which may or may not be improvable with
glasses or contacts afterwards
is called success and so obviously if
you're doing things like
playing sports and spending long times
in the field in alone
and you rely on your eyesight that
doesn't actually sound like success
so um i don't know if that surgery has
improved since then but i guarantee you
that given that
like teeth eyes change over time like
like
teeth change in terms of where they are
positioned over time and they actually
have a dynamic tension in the jaw
as you heard bret talking about with
mike mu in the evolutionary dentistry
episode
we know that the eye changes shape over
time and it also becomes
harder the cornea becomes harder over
time and this is pos this is a large
part of what like
middle-aged uh presbyopia is about is um
not being able to move back and forth
between different focal lengths as
quickly
so the idea of these quick fixes
um that will simply correct you into
perfection uh really ignores almost
everything about what we are
as organisms and you want to say
something about you know so
i yeah i would say one
we are screwing children up two
part of this is natural in other words
the invention of printed
material creates a dynamic that is
unnatural
and the value of printed material is
presumably
high so by
having people read at a close distance
we are disrupting a system in which the
development of the eye would be normal
this is likely
the reason that we have so much eye
dysfunction the idea that it is
genetically encroached encroachment of
mutations is nonsense just as it is with
the teeth
but two things one
the eye takes its shape in large measure
because of the musculature within the
eye which adjusts the eye
based on the distortion not within the
eye but the extrinsic eye muscles around
the eyeball well i don't want to
say too much because i don't know but
yes you've got extrinsic eye muscles
there may also be
endogenous stuff but the basic point is
you are built
to fix your own vision right how do you
do that on the basis
of information about the distortion in
your vision
what happens if you take distorted
vision and you correct it
externally well now the data coming in
results in you not fixing your own
vision
in a context where you're going to
destroy your own vision by
focusing very closely and this is going
to be screens too
now here's the part maybe you don't see
coming it's kind of like taking the
anti-fragility away from
the feedback system between person and i
like you yes you you create a fragile
system where it was antifragile it did
correct from it did correct on the basis
of
insults that came in and insults being
wow that thing is out of focus i really
can't see what that thing is oh i keep
on running into things out of focus
maybe the extrinsic eye muscles or you
know whatever it is need to change
uh the curvature of my lens such that
that thing that i keep on running into
that keeps on being out of focus is no
longer out of focus
right exactly um and you know look
you've got a
basically a video camera made out of
biological goo
right it's not going to be perfect it's
not precision ground so the idea that
musculature is going to correct for
those distortions
that's a marvelous beautiful biological
solution to a biological problem
you now take a ground glass lens
and you distort the the information
coming in
preventing the eye from fixing itself
now what have you got
well it is almost a definition of
fragility because the fact is all of you
folks who walk around needing glasses
are dependent on the
mechanism that produces glasses what
would you do if civilization came apart
and it wasn't making glasses anymore
right
so you've been rendered you'd be you're
rendered fragile by this
and it's not that serious in a world
where lots of people are wearing glasses
and civilization can produce them
but it is a solvable problem in the
following sense
a we probably now have the technology we
didn't
50 years ago but we probably now have
the technology to take whatever
close focus work kids need to do in
order to
educate themselves or whatever and to
place it in a context where it appears
to be far away like imagine that you are
reading a book on a screen in a movie
theater
30 feet from you right that might change
the dynamics so you didn't destroy your
own vision in reading
you know so i don't love at all the idea
of kids wearing
vr goggles that place printed material
effectively 30 feet from them in order
not to destroy their vision but i like
it a lot better than destroying their
vision
so maybe there's some way it could be
done that wouldn't be so intrusive but
at the very least
this is the same thing that we were just
talking about all right
we're screwed up let's not screw up
another generation
of eyes right let's let the next
generation of kids
have normal eyes and normal teeth by
fixing the thing that we do that screws
up
every generation upon arrival yeah so
one one thing just to
one more thing now but we will continue
to talk about this
to your question should kids wear
glasses one thing that
uh we have suggested is uh on
you know if if your kid is myopic and
he or she is at risk like really does
seem to need some correction in order to
move around the universe
consider under correcting yeah consider
uh you know whatever their diopter is
correcting one you know half stop
full stop that's camera language but you
know whatever whatever it is
um below that um such that their eyes
you know an ophthalmologist is gonna
like this just like most dentists don't
wanna hear what um you know what mike
mew has to say but
you know the kid who has to squint a
little bit um to see the thing but can
make it out
their eyes are likely to keep on working
to get it right
and rather than give them the fully
cushy oh this is great i could just
relax into well failing further
yep right so along these lines let me
just say that as a kid
i was diagnosed with i've forgotten i
definitely was diagnosed with
astigmatism and who knows what else
and i was given glasses that i was
supposed to wear as a kid i was supposed
to be wearing
bifocals and
i basically thought
[ __ ] that and so i didn't wear them ever
my eyes corrected themselves and i had
vision that needed no correction
whatsoever until i got to 50 and reading
glasses became a thing
um but the point is that was
an anecdotal demonstration of the fact
that the eyes given the opportunity
given data that actually comes in
normally
were in a position to fix themselves
where i was being told
you know that i had a problem that
required intervention and
just you know if we're doing anecdote as
you know
my anecdotal experience runs runs not at
all like that right like my parents
discovered that i was
already having trouble seeing when we
were on vacation and they were going
look at the beautiful waterfalls across
the ravine and i was like
i don't i don't see them they took me to
the eye doctor i already had 2200 vision
and i got contacts very quickly and
within a few years i had 2800 vision
where it has basically
you know within four or five years it
just like shot down to 2 800.
well i don't know that that story goes
in the opposite direction yeah
but and then it just it stabilized
kind of getting slightly slightly
slightly better now um
that sort of the the middle age
presbyopia is also setting in but yeah
um the diopter is basically
um down at like negative seven negative
six point five
and um there's
i was already not seeing all that well
but not saying anything about it because
it just seemed like what was normal
right but you had your nose buried in
books and you were reading music
hours a day but i was also outside
playing sports and running around right
but my point is that may be a job
that that breadth of activity and the
feedbacks in it may be beyond the
capacity of the eyes to figure out how
to correct and it may have biased in one
direction and not the other
who knows but at the very least hey you
know we need
evolutionary ophthalmology wouldn't that
be grand if people were actually
studying these questions rationally
not blaming genes which obviously are
not going to be the explanation
here yep um and we stopped screwing up
kids
okay we're gonna get through a couple
more of these because we've only done
four
this hour so far so at least a few more
more than two more
i submitted an article to quillette
today titled letter to awoke heart if it
is accepted i hope it does some good
can i send can i send you a copy by
email
um we have a moderator on
uh who can give you an email address i
think
uh and i'm not going to promise but um
i will be interested to look at it
probably
yep yes uh three people who receive
facebook bans
alex jones brett and rose mcgowan
politics make strange bedfellows the
power of three will set us free
good lord yes
tough one um i find it
weird that the executive of telling
people to do things at the point of a
gun is also looked to as the person to
ask
us to do something i don't know what
that refers to i don't either
i'm sorry i don't know what that refers
to
m sandel critiques meritocracy even if
our opportunities are equal for all
because it legitimates the inequalities
that follow from innate differences in
talent and virtue
thoughts here's a review yeah um a i
don't know who that is
it doesn't matter okay it's clear from
the question yeah i think so too but
here's the here's the problem
you're leaping to the conclusion that
there are going to be large
innate differences right personally i
would argue that is
unlikely to be true there will be
differences
but are they innate immutable
um etc and so anyway we're not going to
know this
until we actually democratize access
right democratizing access is the thing
that will tell us whether or not those
differences are durable but at the very
least
you could build a world and we should
build a world in which
access is democratized you do have
meritocracy which properly incentivizes
people to
produce cool stuff that enriches
humanity
in which you are protected from bad luck
that is to say you're not
going to be you're not going to fall off
the bottom of the ladder
if you tried and failed and the fact is
in such a context differences in
well-being are tolerable
you don't want extreme differences in
well-being you don't want
concentration of opportunity but
the world in which we are all rendered
equally well off is not a desirable
world for one thing
if you built that world where we were
all equally well off
it has a huge defect in it too which is
that it makes people well off who didn't
do anything
and therefore is effectively punishing
those who contribute most so
what i would say what a conclusion i
came to in a
conversation i had last week was that
there's a difference between those of us
who think equality is the objective
and those of us who think it's a means
to an end and the fact is
equality of opportunity as means to an
end is
the prerequisite for
the best system that we have come up
with and probably the best one possible
equality of outcome is a
devastating and terrible system and
there's really a huge difference between
these things
uh fyi jordan peterson describes the
maps of meaning logo
as the meaning of music um yeah i think
we already
yeah but yes provided a link to that
description so it might be that
the answer to my question is buried in
that video great
thank you some weeks ago you could not
identify freedom is slavery
in the current movement um that being
from
that being one of the three hey stop
sweetie um that being one of the three
sayings in the beginning of 1984 on the
great pyramid
the the ministry of truth i think
freedom implies responsibility for your
own life for a lot of people
responsibility feels a lot like slavery
freedom is slavery is therefore hotter
but shorter that's interesting i think
that's
yeah quite right yeah good uh keep up
the terrific work guys
thank you all right that's not a bad
idea enough with the partisan mods i
know you support free expression
i don't think our mods are partisan i'm
sure they make decisions that not
everyone agrees with all the time but uh
we know
who they are and they are awesome so i'm
sure they're partisan but i don't know
which party
actually yes yes actually yeah they uh
yeah yes um
do you two plan to write in peter
bogosian for mayor if i lived there i
would
hardest part of that choice is spelling
it
well you spelled it correctly um
um no i i love peter
yeah i think he'd make a much better
mayor than either of these
crazy people um that said
you got to understand what we're
actually facing in portland and it's not
that we have seen an effort that makes
peter a viable candidate so i think
this is that and heather and i have
talked about this at length that there's
a very different logic that unfolds
inside of our local election that
unfolds in our presidential
national election um so i would just say
this is not uh this is not the place for
a symbolic
challenge to um the two other mayoral
candidates this is a case where
uh iran irony
has to be defeated because iannarone
has to be defeated because um
she is going to make a terrible
situation vastly worse
so um there's no duopoly in portland in
fact that's part of the
it's not part of the problem there just
aren't even two parties there's just no
republicans
anywhere close so there's no tension
between like democrats and republicans
here we've got wheeler
who's uh like the george bridges of
portland which is an evergreen reference
he's
woke he's weak he's ridiculous um
uh i think he means well somewhere deep
in his heart and he
just barely began to speak out against
antifa in the last week or two at which
point ianna rhone
who identifies as an anti-fascist uh
responded to him and said he was alright
and
playing you know footsie with white
nationalists i don't know if he said
that
she said that last part but she said the
first part
she's crazy he is an incompetent boob
he's a democrat i don't know what she
calls herself
but in portland unlike at the national
scale
votes actually have a chance of of
mattering
and it's not a duopoly we aren't being
forced to
decide between the lesser of two evils
even though
whaler is an incompetent boob but uh if
vienna rhone
gets the mayorship of portland
portland may well fall like i don't know
if portland can
can withstand that she is she is an
extremely dangerous character
you know it's refreshing to hear an
endorsement of a candidate
with the phrase incompetent boob that's
not common
that people make endorsements in that
kind of language i just i
you know i'm i feel free not to vote for
either of the decrepit clowns in the
national election
i hate it i wish i could vote for
someone who i hoped would win but i
won't vote for either of them
i'm voting for the incompetent boob for
portland i wish i could vote for
for pete he's a friend of ours and we we
love him and um
he would make a better mayor but he
won't win and therefore
the vote actually feels like um it's
important not to
not to make a symbolic vote um for the
portland mayor i hate to say it
yeah but yeah
okay
here we go our views often don't quite
line up but i really appreciate the
contributions you both provide the
discourse keep up the great work i
appreciate you both
thank you you mentioned that you used to
smoke copious amounts of marijuana that
caused you to develop an allergy
what was the allergy you developed and
if you were able to get rid of it
by quitting uh haven't gotten rid of it
the allergy is just a
reaction in my lungs and interestingly
the reaction in my lungs
happens even if i eat it
so yeah that's true isn't it yeah um
there's something about you know
my immune system took it to be a hostile
force
learned to fight it and now if it shows
up by any means even through the gut
um my lungs react and they fill with goo
yeah um so you know it's fine
i i yeah i had more than my share sorry
that's right i don't need it and i don't
miss it frankly
yeah um okay we're actually gonna get
through the questions that are here now
even though god it's late but um
we're gonna get through the rest of
these this hour um
check out kirk sorensen and gordon
mcdowell's and others
efforts to advance thorium within the
nuclear industry
it looks to be safe here so looks to be
safer and more abundant but a barrier
seems to be an entrenched uranium fuel
industry
yep no doubt so you know something about
this oh i sure do
i sure do and i remain to be convinced
that thorium is safe enough
but yes if you were going to be serious
about fission power
this would be one of the mechanisms you
would want to be looking very carefully
at it is
clearly safer and better and you know
of course the uranium fission industry
is not interested
right one do you see a parallel between
neurodiversity
movement and the crt movement in the
sense that both regard the world is a
construct founded on exploitation of
diverse groups
two do you support shock-based treatment
of autism
wow i've never heard of shock-based
treatment of autism i
doubt it but i would have to hear more i
don't think so
um have you heard about this no okay but
i mean
the second one's easy yeah right i don't
know exactly how you
run the experiments but the answer is uh
if it helps and helps has to be defined
as
um you know in some integrative way
you're
more capable i don't know happier
more fulfilled i just don't think we
have a good enough model of autism i
mean
oh i don't think we do if if you're
talking about people who are
you know deeply
unable to function in the world um
for whom something like that might help
then then maybe but there's
there's so many high-functioning
autistic people for whom right um
i mean certainly wouldn't this wouldn't
be about requiring it of
yeah i just but
okay on the first one uh do you see a
parallel between the neurodiversity
movement and critical race theory
movement
um in the sense that both both regard
the world's a construct founded on
exploitation of diverse groups
yeah that's not how i see the
neurodiversity movement at all the
problem with this one
yeah i would say not at all on the other
hand i think we've been down this road
with the term anti-racist where
as viewers of the podcast will remember
first time i heard the term it was
applied to me and i thought that's great
i felt honored to be included in the
category
anti-racist and i found out it's narrow
definition and it's like no i don't want
to touch that with a barge pole
but um so the point here
is you know neurodiversity as i think
people in our circle who talk about it
mean
is just the you know frankly there's a
lot of
value that has been brought to the world
by people who have things that would be
considered deficits by many including
high functioning autism
high functioning autism you know
dyslexics
whatever it is and so in fact i did i
did a big think video about this
years ago yeah yeah so to the extent
that neurodiversity is simply the
recognition
that even stuff where we're really
talking about some kind of damage
that results in you having a different
view of the world can be very positive
and you know
the term i use for myself and many
students
was misfit because misfit does not place
judgment
on whether it's you or the system that's
uh a bad match or could be both but you
know so
there's a very intuitive reason to
defend neurodiversity and not
look to stamp it out on the other hand
crt
is obviously a um
an insane bastardization of a real
recognition that there is some
historical biases built into the way we
think about
about race so has neurodiversity become
some sort of a toxic claim or is it
headed that direction and then we should
be wary of it if so we're not aware of
it yet
so i don't see the parallel but it could
emerge
yeah can we push back against this
memory hole in some way
i.e setting up a repository and
decentralized server with censored
deleted content
i feel like there are some movements
like that um
happening in fact one is called the
memory hole now
i think there's a site called the memory
hole okay um
but yes we have to push back and also i
would say
that to the extent that something that
does not have your interests at heart
doesn't want you discussing something
you have
an above average or above normal
obligation to think carefully about it
right whatever it is that they don't
want us talking about we should be
talking about so
if you're not talking about the
implications of
hunter biden's peddling influence in the
form of
his vp father you should be thinking
about it whether you're voting for biden
or not you should be thinking about the
implications that a biden win
is an influence peddler taking office
and you should also be thinking about
the fact that some of us were telling
you that from the beginning
yep so next question from the author of
this cyclical evolution hypothesis
he i think clarifies the cyclical the
cyclical evolutionary hypothesis
presents a self-driven
population-wide multi-generational
oscillating
hormone cycle so it's an intrinsic
system
okay it does sound like um
integral theory in in some ways yeah so
it does you know the idea that there
might be some cyclical pattern
um
might well be i still i still want to
understand it
can't be hormone driven yeah right it's
got to be hormones have to be driven by
something else
exactly um but hi
there is a risk is there a risk that the
increase
of environmentalism in the west is going
to create a new form of colonialism
wherein rich nations intervene in other
countries with the idea to protect
gaia's resources
it's already happening um hi
yes we've been on way too long
apparently
um yeah it's it absolutely is already
happening you know the
the the us got to basically cut down a
lot of our forests
and is now making a point of telling
other people not to and i'm thinking
about
um what is it institut
biodiversidad yeah in costa rica
um which i think actually was is pretty
honorable and i hope still
exists but back when we were in graduate
school we spent um
a couple of seasons and a couple of
field seasons in costa rica
and uh were given a tour by our
professor
of inbio which was training uh which was
run by costa rican scientists if i
remember correctly so just
jump in if i get something wrong and
they were training um
poor uh poor costa ricans porticos uh as
what they were calling parataxonists
to basically do collect an id um
and then um and then but they were
working with
big pharma right so they were i think
funded in part by
i don't remember who it was pfizer mark
or something probably mark
and uh merck wasn't able to just come in
like they had been before the
formulation of nbo
and um you know and find lots of
organisms
and take them back to the us or germany
or whatever and um
and create new compounds and you know do
the r d and make make billions on some
drug they now had to actually involve
costa rica
and its resources in the
in the process somewhat but it was it
was more honorable than it had been but
it still had the risk of being predatory
i think
okay but you've got a corrupt version of
something at some level
a we did cut down our force b we cut him
down
long before these dynamics were
understood
yep we might have done it anyway but
it's
in some sense not a fair comparison but
then
c we're also talking about
the world's source of a large fraction
of its biodiversity
housed in these other forests in other
words our northern temperate forests
aren't all that diverse
the amazon for example is fantastically
diverse and extinction
is permanent so losing 100 acres of
amazonian forest
you can't replace that by uh
supporting or growing 100 acres of
boreal forest in canada it's not the
same
it doesn't do anything like the same job
so i think the thing that needs to be
said
is we have not yet worked out the
[Music]
governance structure that properly
reflects
that the arbitrary distribution
of important
biota um is
not the fact that these things fall
within national
borders does not um you know allow
bolsonaro to destroy the
earth's only amazon right because
he's a fruitcake and doesn't understand
biodiversity nor would he care about it
right it's nobody's right to destroy it
right does that mean
every branch on every tree needs to be
preserved
no but we have to work out the structure
in which
those things that belong to humanity are
protected
in perpetuity and we're a long way from
it but yes we do have to this is one of
the things i think the right gets
quite wrong yes we only have one earth
and we are degrading it and that's not
our right and so we have to stop and how
we get there without
placing some people at advantage and
other disadvantages is a topic that
needs to be explored
uh two more they're just comments
incompetent boob 2020
love it yup that's that's what we're
doing yeah competitive
2020. an incompetent boob 2020. i'm not
settling for biden
i'm not voting for either of those not
voting for neither decrepit
i'm just pointing out that it belongs
the settle for biden is an excellent
slogan given biden
yes and incompetent boob 2020 is an
excellent slogan given wheeler yeah
somehow i can get behind the incompetent
boob but neither decrepit clown
yeah yeah do we need to start a plm
puppy lives matter fun the cats seem to
get all the love here
thanks for sharing your time and
knowledge with us all
yeah this is weird because the dog is a
better person
she aspires to be a better person and he
gives a damn about being a good person
yeah cats manifestly don't
anyway yeah it's interesting that the
the the cats seem to get um
more than their share of the milk yes
well off camera maddie
madison here gets uh gets plenty of love
don't you yes she does
yeah all right she will be relieved to
find that we are at the end
of yet another gosh more than an hour by
a lot uh tomorrow
again we will be doing our private q a
which you can find
you will be able to find a link to this
evening on my patreon
uh tomorrow from 11 to 1 11 a.m to 1 p.m
pacific
next weekend will be the first of your
monthly conversations through your
patreon
you can find access to the discord
server at either of them
and we will be back next saturday on
halloween
if not sooner halloween as if you
weren't scared enough
already all right we'll see you then